thanks to notion for sponsoring this
video get your free personal accounts at
the link in the description in this
video we are looking at the planets of
Warhammer 40,000 to establish which ones
could really exist
is this the dorkiest thing I've ever
done on this channel yes does this make
my inner geek and multiple army
collecting self squealed with joy
also yes as before I'm joined by dr.
Hannah waetford of the astrophysics
department University of Bristol to
combine her planetary expertise with my
atmospheric knowledge this is part 2 in
part 1 we looked at planets from Terra
su Tanith and found that most of them
could really exist if you enjoy this
video then you should go give that one a
watch too well if you've already seen it
then welcome back Inquisitor for now we
return to the fray at Cadia Qadir was
the gate to the eye of terror a
temperate fortress world but held back
the tide of chaos until it didn't
anymore Abaddon or Abaddon the Despoiler
destroyed the planet by ploughing an
immense spaceship called a black stone
fortress into its surface for once we're
not so interested in the planet itself
but rather its demise can you actually
destroy a planet with a forceful enough
impact well yes these simulations are
from a researcher called Jacob keager
ice looking at collisions between
planets in their early stages of
formation when they're just proto
planets what you'll notice is that when
collisions occur on this sort of scale
planets don't really behave as a solid
object in fact they actually behave much
more like a fluid depending on the angle
of impact the density of the impacting
object and its velocity the target
planet can become a collection of rocky
debris have ejecta spread all over its
surface or even have its molten core
split in two we may actually have to
thank such a collision for our very
existence we mentioned earlier that the
earth having such a large moon may have
given rise to life itself through tidal
effects and the moon might actually only
be there because of a colossal impact in
the Earth's past one hypothesis is that
around 4.5 billion years ago earth was
struck by a mars-sized object and that
impact caused a huge amount of rock to
be ejected from earth into space that
formed the moon returning to our
discussion of the comet struck Valhalla
transferring as much momentum as would
be required to shift the planet's orbit
via collisions would just pulp the
planet and cause a huge loss of its
atmosphere to space destroying a planet
through collision though absolutely
possible and while we're considering
planet death let's look at another world
that was famously raised it's found
three here at the start of the Horus
heresy the planet and a relatively
standard temperate world had its entire
atmosphere set alight consuming the
whole planet in a firestorm that killed
some eight billion people near instantly
40k the question here is can a whole
atmosphere be ignited this is something
that's actually been calculated for the
earth when the Manhattan Project was
developing nuclear devices there was a
very real concern that the temperatures
reached on destination would cause the
atmosphere to spontaneously combust
calculations by Edward Teller and Emil
Cano Pinsky in the amazingly titled
ignition of the atmosphere with nuclear
bombs showed that no matter how much you
heat the atmosphere it can't start a
self-propagating chain reaction
so just sparking the atmosphere is not
enough you have to add fuel now that is
exactly what the traitors did it is
spawn 3 they used a virus bomb to render
the biomass on the planet down to
methane and corpse gases in mere minutes
then ignited the newly flammable air
from orbit
there's around 500 billion tons of
carbon in the Earth's biosphere so
that's all animals plants microorganisms
everything that's living on the planet
so if we were to somehow perfect can
confer all of the Earth's biomass to
methane then according to my rough
calculations you would certainly have
enough oxygen set on fire you would only
burn around one one thousandth of all
the oxygen in the atmosphere but it
would only burn if the gas remained in
the lowest 50 meters or so the
atmosphere methane only ignites when at
least 5 percent by volume of air and
filling the bottom 50 meters the
atmosphere with methane
just about reaches this 5 percent
threshold that's a problem however when
methane is less dense than air dance
would be rapidly spread out amongst the
bottom ten kilometers or so the
atmosphere by the tropospheric
circulation so using earth as a proxy
for istafan 3 even with the most
generous assumptions about how effective
the virus bombs would be the production
of methane across the whole planet would
almost certainly be too thinly spread to
produce flammable air and anything other
than a couple of hot spots obviously
this is looking at earth not just fun
but fortunately for the loyalists it
seems Horus would have been a little
less effective in reality his span
three's death could not have happened as
described that's enough hypothetical
though let's consider an actual plan for
an actual
an actual plan
guys we're on Casa Chan its space
Vietnam where everything wants to meet
you so I guess basically you know mates
and welcome to counter chair I'll be
your tour guide today just make sure you
watch out for the Venus man traps kind
of chant devil's blood wasps oh and the
flying smoke members hopefully this
afternoon before the party will see some
of the great barking toads or as I like
to call them
Chazz Moses but be careful if you touch
them they they will explode and they
will kill you being a planet-wide jungle
specifically Katich an actually makes
more sense than TANF our previous
planet-wide forests and the simple
reason for that is water biomes can be
defined by how warm and how wet the
local environment is we previously said
that homogeneous climates would make
sense if there was a thick atmosphere
that evenly distributed equatorial heat
around the planet that circulation would
also distribute moisture and on a
uniformly warm planet with liquid water
on the surface there would be plenty of
water vapor held in the air as air gets
warmer it can store more water in the
form of vapor so a planet that has a
thick atmosphere at the right distance
from its star would both be warm all
over and wet all over and when those
conditions combine you get rain forests
and when you get enough rain forests you
get enhanced evaporation adding more
moisture to the atmosphere this in turn
can cause a rise in sea levels covering
more of the planet and water will lead
to more evaporation and so on it is a
positive feedback loop the wildlife
being so dangerous could also make sense
as with such a crowded ecosystem as we
see in Earth's jungles animals engage in
an arms race to compete for resources
when the planet is one huge jungle
teeming with life the competition for
resources is fierce much like the whole
galaxy really even has the skeletons in
fact Kathy Chan is not a million miles
away from Earth during the Jurassic
period when co2 concentrations were so
high around two-and-a-half times current
concentrations that there was very
little difference between equatorial and
polar temperatures there were plenty of
shallow seas dense forests and
rainforests even at the poles and of
course plenty of animals that would kill
you and everyone you love so yeah
Kathir German is possible a million
miles from Earth both physically and
metaphorically is Portmore one of the
most important harbours of the Imperial
Navy it's not really a planet at all but
more of an enormous Space Station
possibly constructed and then abandoned
by the necrons
the really distinctive thing about
Portmore is the fanged mouth that runs
across the center of the planetoid
rendering the interior of the entirely
hollow structure accessible and
defensible sources list the mouth as
being 500 kilometers wide which if we
interpret to mean it's longitude a'l
width Portmore would have a radius of
around 160 kilometers so this is a
pretty small object in terms of planets
but vast in terms of spaceships it's
bigger than the Death Star for goodness
sake in the past we discussed know where
a similar spaceport in the MCU
but unlike Portmore that was built from
the skull of a celestial and was much
smaller in scale we previously ruled
that nowhere could possibly exist
because we don't know the exact material
properties of the skull similarly we
don't know what material Portmore is
made of like relieve necro dermis or
similar but the sheer scale of the
object means that the gravitational
effects of its ace ferocity will be much
greater see a MCU video for more details
about what that means for a material to
be strong enough to hold this shape
while also being light enough to not
produce a catastrophic ly destructive
gravitational field especially
considering that it doesn't have
spherical symmetry like a Dyson Sphere
it would have to have properties
completely unlike any metal we yet know
about for that reason I am going to have
to say that it couldn't exist if we came
across this world tomorrow
I'm pretty sure that whatever material
is made of will break some of the laws
of physics the Primarch who broke all
the laws of social etiquette was Mort
Aryan who you could definitely smell
before you saw however considering the
old Morty grew up on the world of
barbarous this makes sense the planet
had a horrific atmosphere and I don't
mean as if someone at a party just
admitted that they play towel the
atmosphere and barbarous was only
breathable very close to the surface as
you got higher reaching out of the
valleys where the population lived
virulent toxic gases increased in
concentration and would
quickly overwhelm any human this is an
interesting idea but there are some
physical problems with this there are
basically two ways that we can have
distinct chemical layers in an
atmosphere above the surface the first
is the stratosphere hello the
stratosphere is a unique layer in the
Earth's atmosphere where temperature
increases with altitude which results in
the air there lying in flat layers on
top of one another
this means that if you inject something
to the stratosphere such as with a
volcanic eruption it gets circulated
around on these flat layers but
basically stays up there on barbarous if
there was a source of these toxic gases
in the stratosphere then they would stay
up there basically permanently the
problem is the stratosphere starts much
higher up than halfway up a valley and
its lowest on earth it's maybe six or
seven kilometers above the surface
if barbarous is sun emitted more UV than
our Sun does then maybe a stratosphere
would be lower but it's star is
described as weak in yellow which if
anything would mean it would emit less
UV radiation and so the stratosphere
would be higher so this seems a very
unlikely explanation the other section
in the Earth's atmosphere where layers
of different gases are stacked on top of
one another is in the heterosphere this
is where convection and mixing are less
important than diffusion of molecules by
their different weights so you get
layers of the heaviest gases on the
bottom and the lightest gas is on top
below the heterosphere everything is
basically mixed together equally what's
called the hama spear
however the boundary between these two
layers the turbo pause is there about a
hundred kilometers above the surface
much higher than the stratosphere and
the heterosphere contains just one
thousandth of a percent of all the mass
in the atmosphere so barbarous isn't
going to have its dense lower atmosphere
explained by a heterosphere in fact
Barbarossa's atmosphere is kind of the
opposite of how we experience pollution
on earth when you see pictures like this
of smog hanging over a city it's caused
by what's called a temperature inversion
just like in the stratosphere where an
air temperature increases with height
which it can for a variety of reasons it
stops vertical movement of air this
traps pollution in a layer underneath
the cooler air above this is often seen
in cities in valleys such as Salt Lake
City so barbarous is pollute
upper atmosphere rather than lower
atmosphere is the opposite of what we
expect from this temperature inversion
phenomenon if barbarous had a permanent
temperature inversion close to the
surface for some bizarre reason and the
source of the pollution was above this
layer then conceivably there would be a
habitable lower section in the
atmosphere rapidly meeting this toxic
layer but I just don't think it's
possible for such sharp division to
permanently exist in the Hamas here
where everything is mixed together so
fortunately I'm gonna say that barbarous
couldn't exist we're gonna have to
include at least one we've world or
we'll get over watched to death when we
asked on reddit for suggestions for this
video wondering the kept coming up was
10 ik la Hanna Tennant claw was
originally a huge mineral structure with
a thin crust the towel earth cast then
got their fishy little hands on it and
used their advanced technology to carve
it into an enormous truncated
icosahedron a mix of hexagons and
pentagons approximating a sphere the
planet sized crystal is described as
being so close to true transparency it
seems to glow with lambent starlight
crystals appear transparent when they
have no fractures or impurities such as
transitional elements in them so for a
crystal to grow to the size of a planet
it would need to form in some pretty
exceptional circumstances and a great
deal of pressure over a long period of
time and in a stable environment without
extra elements floating around one
possibility for such an environment is
the core of a planet at the center of
gas giants like Jupiter the pressure and
temperature can be immense and depending
on the material present in the planet
crystal formation seems likely one
hypothetical origin for a world like
tinted glass is a low-density planet
that gradually formed crystals in its
solid core and subsequently lost its
atmosphere and outer layers to intense
radiation from its star we see this
process happening with some exoplanets
such as GJ 3470 B which is slowly losing
its hydrogen helium envelope due to
pressure from the star this would leave
behind a large crystal core which could
then
later accrete a sink rust as tinted
glass seems to have done however in such
circumstances there would still be
plenty of other elements kicking around
in the planet and so the resulting
crystal wouldn't be transparent at all
in fact there's no evidence to suggest
that such large crystals could form
anywhere in nature so much as planets
could to have their outer layers
stripped away to leave a core behind one
exactly like the crystalline 10x law
does not seem possible but enough xenos
and traitorous filth let's go back to
the sol system to finish off this video
and examine two worlds at the heart of
the Imperium and Hannah is pretty
excited to talk about the homeworld of
the grey night's Titan whoo Titan is one
of the most fascinating worlds in our
solar system it is the only moon to
harbor a stable atmosphere in fact the
atmosphere is denser than the Earth's at
one point four times the pressure at the
surface Titan's atmosphere like Earth's
is nitrogen based in them it is mostly
made of nitrogen but all the other gunk
in Titan's atmosphere is not oh - but
methane it actually also has a methane
cycle much like our water cycle here on
earth a methane cycle on titan rains
down forming lakes and seas and then
evaporates and rains down again the
surface of Titan is cold just 90 degrees
above absolute zero and the surface
itself is formed of ice it is formed of
water ice and every mountain and feature
you see there is an ice mountain this
little sphere is then sitting on a layer
of liquid water which is itself on top
of hot ice ice 6 which is formed when
water is under immense pressure even in
40k it seems that they basically threw
in the towel and just accepted the
environment of Titan as unchangeable so
kept it as a defense after all it's one
of the more hellish environments for an
enemy to try and attack and that's
before you even account for the chapter
of MarySue goody-two-shoes Harry Potter
Marines on the surface Titan in 40k is
basically the Titan we know today so it
could definitely exist
I love Titan it's such an amazing world
and I can see why they chose it for the
planetary science fun alone crazy little
Marines our final world though returning
closer
home is very different to what we see in
the present day Mars
god damn it I love toasters Mars is the
homeworld of the adept Asst mechanicus
the tech support of the Imperium and a
colossal power in their own right in the
41st millennium Mars is a forge world
with a population of some 20 billion
souls and an unspecified number of catan
let's take a look at the differences
between Mars now and Mars then firstly
it's missing a moon Deimos
was relocated over Titan to act as a
massive mine and later fortress for the
grey knights so yeah there's that
secondly the ring of iron a huge complex
of orbital facilities probably the
largest man-made structure in the galaxy
effectively a series of tethered space
stations that ring the entire planet and
terraforming Mars had been colonized for
tens of thousands of years by m41 and
was previously entirely terraformed to
be a verdant world however when the
mechanical took control of the planet
they totally disregarded the environment
and wrecked the atmosphere in their
quest for greater industrial and
military production the question of
terraforming Mars has been considered
for years from as soon as it became
clear that the planet was extremely
hostile to human life in its current
form the verdict is still out on whether
is actually possible to make Mars
habitable partly due to the energy that
is required to release enough greenhouse
gas to warm the surface yes you could
use nukes musk but you really really
wouldn't want to but also it's going to
be difficult because of the lack of
magnetosphere on Mars and the
magnetosphere is important because it
would shield it from the solar wind
we can't kickstart the planets core to
give it this new magnetosphere and any
magnetic shielding from space would only
be partially effective though in the
past we've ruled that extremely advanced
technology can accomplish a great deal
and seeing as Mars is the home of the
biggest calm ski nerds in the galaxy
let's give them the benefit of the doubt
and say they would be able to terraform
the planet but would they consciously
wreck an entire planet ruin its
atmosphere no that does just too far
fast oh yeah the other standout feature
on the forge world is the ring of iron
if you have a galaxy-wide Empire to draw
on then you could definitely build
something this big and it being an
equatorial ring means that dynamic
it makes sense provided of course that
it wasn't rigid James Clark Maxwell
showed that if a planet had a solid
rigid ring it would be unstable and tear
itself apart so the ring of iron would
need to have compensating mechanisms and
mechanics in different ways to avoid
this together with sufficiently strong
material to tether it to the equator it
seems like the ring of iron could exist
and so the forge world principle could -
if we're being super generous and there
we are
of the 18 planets considered ten could
probably exist in our galaxy and oh boy
will we be worse off for having any of
them next though we should consider
which forms of heresy could really exert
so far we've now looked at planets from
40k star wars and the MCU
and we've seen a wide variety of planets
40k might actually showcase some of the
coolest kinds of planets yet including
tidally locked worlds as well as my
favorite moon Titan what's like our
universe should we look at next though
by flight Stargate agents of shield
bonus points if you can find a sci-fi
universe with a hot Jupiter there are so
many more kinds of exoplanets that we
never seem to get represented in sci-fi
and we would love to take a look at some
more the universe is really strange and
we still have yet to scratch the surface
on these videos
[Music]
ya see yep you can definitely check that
one off must remember to do that later
buy incense in case you're wondering
this is how I produce and organize my
videos each one has a page in my
database CERN has custom assets that
allow me to keep track of for example
video type status and target date my
video database is only part of my
personal notion I'll use this same free
software to keep track of my weekly
to-do lists yearly planning and what
bits of plastic Kraken gonna buy next
notion is kind of like a life OS a
software version of Lego bricks that you
can use to construct whatever system you
want for your specific needs
students can use notion to help organize
their notes teams can use notion to
coordinate tasks and couples can use it
to plan their weddings to a completely
same level of detail if you like how
someone else has configured their notion
then it's super easy to duplicate their
system in terrain and almost all of my
various systems started life this way
customization is super easy and one of
my favorite things about notion best of
all though personal accounts used to be
$5 a month but are now free forever
notion has been an absolute game changer
for my productivity my organization and
my general mental health and I would
honestly recommend it to absolutely
anyone especially now that you can get a
personal account for free there is no
reason to not give it a go sign up at
the link in the description for your
free personal account and unlock your
productive potential it really is that
good
thanks to notion for sponsoring and
helping me organize this video thank you
so much for watching this video as with
part 1 this was a mammoth task that
would not been possible without the
unending support of Magus Hannah do
check out the description for a link to
her website and research thanks must
also go to jungle fighter Remi and to
tech priest spiffing Britt and lending
me their voices and to server tools
silently for fat checking some of the
script if you enjoyed this video please
do pop it a like and give it a share in
your hobby group chat that just leads me
to say thank you so much again for
watching and as always the Emperor
protects
[Music]